had a business secretary Jonathan
Reynolds thank you very much for being
with us this morning
um firstly I just want to look at
reports in the newspapers this morning
that Labor's looking at changing the
voting system to allow settled migrants
so people who may be citizens of other
countries but live work pay taxes in the
UK and also 16 and 17 year olds to have
the vote what's the plan
well good morning look the some of the
speculation that's been in the Press
about Labor policy actually relates to
our policy making process it's not our
Manifesto It's not a statement of party
policy but it's how we go about doing
that we've got a process where people
put in their submissions they're
deliberated on they're voted upon so
this is not a statement of policy yet
but of course we're always looking at
ways to strengthen our democracy to
involve as many people impossible as
that and there'll be an element of that
the reform of how this country operates
how power is shared in the labor
Manifesto that's for sure
do you personally think it would be a
good idea to allow settled migrants and
16 17 year olds to navigate them
well I think there are Arguments for
expanding the franchise it's not an area
I directly deal with in the shadow
cabinet so I'm not going to give a
definitive answer on that but I think we
should always be seeking to involve as
many people as possible in our democracy
that's what strengthens Democratic
politics that's what we need to see
encouraged and I think we haven't seen
enough of that in recent times so it's
something we will we will look at but
some of the reports as I've got to
stress they're not the fair final plans
for the labor Manifesto this is about
the process by which we achieve that
Manifesto I mean it could be a pretty
big expansion of the franchise if it was
to be a labor policy one that could also
potentially make it easier for labor to
earn an election
I don't think any changes to how the
British State Works how democracy Works
should be ever considered through any
kind of party political lens it should
be about what is right for the country
what is the right way to make politics
work better and that will be the only
criteria we would put forward but it
certainly wouldn't be any consideration
the partisan advantage
of course never and thank you
um for giving us a bit of a steer I
guess on the policy at least now kirst
armor says his labor party will have to
be Clause 4 on steroids so that of
course is the moment when Tony Blair
rewrote the labor Constitution to ditch
its commitment to nationalization I mean
that's pretty big talk so what is it
specifically that you want to do
well gear is laying out the scale of the
challenge and as we saw in the local
elections when I got to polling day the
big questions for people in this country
are are they better off after 13 years
of conservative government do they think
any public services work better after
those 13 years and the scale of the
challenge therefore for labor it's not
just turning around an economy that
hasn't functioned very well for 13 years
it's the complete reform and delivery on
public services in a way where they need
the scale of that I don't think has ever
been greater and specifically for me on
the economic side of the shuttle cabinet
that's bringing the kind of modern
industrial strategy we see in other
countries we see many parts of our
company Automotive sectors a good
example we're stressing today where you
need the state to be active a partner to
draw in the kind of private investment
that we're seeing in the U.S through
things like the inflation production act
but we haven't had a response here to
that in the UK you know the fact that
the UK has the lowest business
investment in the G7 with all the good
things all the strength and Innovation
that we have in the UK these are major
problems and Kiera is laying out the sky
scale of the challenge and his ambition
and our ambition to meet that challenge
um it's you you feel to me I guess that
labor very good at laying out the scale
of the challenge but what we haven't
heard so much are of are like specific
policy ideas I mean you can point to
radical Blair policies the minimum wage
for example in a speech starmer even
compares his government to the labor
government in 1945 when the National
Health Service was first set up and I
haven't really heard much on that scale
from this current labor team despite the
rhetoric is it that you don't have the
ideas or you just don't want to tell us
right now what they are
no I think our job is to is to
articulate those and get them across so
what I'm talking about specifically here
I would say look at our pledge to reform
business rates of fundamental change of
the business rate system to change the
apprenticeship Levy to let firms spend
up to half of their apprenticeship Levy
funds on other forms of training I would
look at our changes our promise changes
to the planning system to have an
industrial strategy to begin with to put
in significant public investment through
our green Prosperity fund to leverage in
the kind of private investment we need
to see and to make brexit work so if
your specific policies on rejoining the
Horizon Science Program on agreeing a
Veterinary agreement with the EU on
having the mutual recognition of
professional qualifications I'd say
these are all detailed things now what
we saw in those local elections was
clearly the conservative party rejected
and people choosing labor over the
conservatives but we know we've got more
to do none of us are complacent we've
got to get that message across of the
scale of our ambition of the hope we
want to deliver back to the country and
why these specific policies that we've
got deserve a hearing and that they are
the answers to the problems so look we
know we've got more to do but I don't
accept the case that we're not putting
forward specific policies because I
actually think compared to many
oppositions a year or 18 months before a
general election we've got far more on
the table than most political parties
usually have at this stage I'm not
saying that you're not put putting
forward specific policies I'm just
talking about the scale of it when you
look at the rhetoric from kids Dharma
it's going to be these Clause foreign
steroids we're going to talk talking
about the 1945 labor win you know
they're talking about policies like the
NHS like the minimum wage you know you
mentioned the inflation reduction Act of
the US that's 369 billion dollars worth
of policy and one of the policies you
mentioned is allowing firms to spend
half the apprenticeship levy on other
things I'm just talking about the scale
of what you're putting forward
well I actually think the aggregate
scale of what we're putting forward a
very different approach to the economy a
very different approach to Public
Services is worthy of that and actually
many times you mentioned those previous
governments people at the times would
have said this isn't ambitious enough
this is a significant enough it's only
in retrospect you really get the sense
of scale on that but just to look at
what we're putting forward in my area
we're in business and Industrial
strategy this is a very significant
change it's real public money it's not
trying to match by the way the scale of
inflation production act because I don't
think we can do that as a nation of our
skies and scale but it is a very
different approach to what we see at the
minute which is a government that has
some quite eye-catching industrial
targets but no way to deliver that we're
promising the money that would go in to
bring in that private investment the
changes to things like planning and the
regulation of the National Grid that
would facilitate that changes to the
skills system to business taxation you
add that up and that is a compelling and
comprehensive package it's not the full
picture yet of course there'll be more
for the manifesto but I do think it's
the kind of change that we need to turn
around living standards and of course
provide the revenue that gives us the
chance to improve public services to the
level the British people expect
we had gone shots on the program earlier
he said that the mood in the
conservative party is one of Steely
determination how would you class it
I'm not an objective Observer of the
conservative party but I think it seems
quite demoralized and has ever you know
full of internal conflicts and battles I
I look at conservative MPS and I think
to be honest many of them are looking
perhaps to a post-election period and
the succession and who might take over
but look we can't be distracted by that
we know we've got a mission to do to you
know we've turned the labor party around
since 2019 in terms of its perception
and the trust the public have been it we
know we've got to go further with more
people over perhaps do more on the hope
and optimism as well as the reassurance
and credibility that we've had to
re-establish so whatever the moon and
the conservative party is it doesn't
detract from the mission that we've got
in the labor party okay Jonathan
Reynolds thank you very much indeed
Johnson Reynolds there for the labor
party